bonjour la voie est libre tous les
samedis sur france 3 est au bout d'une
semaine où des milliers de voix se sont
élevées contre le projet de loi travail
nous prolongeons de débats avec quatre
voies politiques aujourd'hui françois
rebsamen maire socialiste de dijon
bonjour nos jours vous êtes ancien
ministre du travail donc spécialiste du
dossier
guillaume larrivé députée diane bonjour
bonjour vous êtes un des quatre porte
parole nationaux du parti des
républicains à la raymond représentants
ici du front de gauche bonjour mon jeu
vous êtes représentant du front de
gauche de l'yonne et antoine tu dis que
vous êtes conseiller régional de saône
et loire pour le front national
bonjour à vous bonjour alors pour tout
vous dire en préparant cette
introduction il y a quelques jours
j'avais écrit des millions de voix et
puis finalement les chiffres de la
mobilisation de mercredi sont plus
modestes la fourchette va de deux cent
cinquante mille à cinq cent mille
personnes
quelle lecture faites vous de la semaine
écoulée françois rebsamen est ce que
vous partagez la vie de jean marie le
guen le ministre qui a dit la
mobilisation n'a pas fait la
démonstration du reçu non je ne prête
pas ce type de commentaire sur ce texte
puisque selon je m'aperçois c'est qu'il
ya eu une mauvaise présentation je pense
qui a nui aux textes avant même qu'il
soit sorti puisque j'ai trouvé que
c'était une maladresse même d'annoncer à
l'avancé éventuellement que c'était je
passerai avec à 49,3 a eu l'heur de
braquer une partie de la majorité de
gauche à l'assemblée et donc moi je
pense qu'il faut négocier toujours
négocier écouter et tenir compte de ce
que diront les organisations patronales
et syndicales notamment les syndicats
réformistes avec lesquels nous voulons
annoncé hillion l'arrivée quel regard
vous portiez ce que les républicains
entendaient de faire les comptes
aussi non ce qui compte c'est le fond il
ya 5 millions sept cent mille chômeurs
en france il ya dans notre pays une
exaspération et une inquiétude
extrêmement forte
et face à cela il ya une urgence et de
décider ce que j'attends moi c'est comme
député à l'assemblée nationale d'être
saisie d'un projet de loi portant
réforme du marché du travail par un
avant avant projet de loi des mesures
concrètes se lie depuis voilà entrons
dans le travail technique article après
article pour essayer de voter ou pas des
mesures utiles je suis député
d'opposition mais j'ai envie de
travailler sur le fond sur un texte
solide et pour l'instant on est un peu
comme sera non on ne voit pas venir ce
contexte on va quand même essayer de
venir dans cette émission sur le sur le
fond du texte à la raymond beaucoup de
syndicats très engagé et du monténégro
temps vous avez été déçus des chiffres
n'ont jamais été des chiffres et des
sites d'issue c'est la première
manifestation qui avait lieu on sait
très bien que au moment du cpe c'était
la même chose au départ savez comment
c'est un peu comme ça d'ailleurs on est
à peu près sur les mêmes chiffres
donc il y avait du monde il ya surtout
aussi des sondages qui disent qu'une
majorité de français sont contre ce
projet et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que chez les jeunes ils sont 68% à dire
non à ce projet et non un non ferme et
91% les bacs pros et plus connaissent ce
texte
j'étais mercredi matin mardi matin la
veille de la manifestation a distribué
devant les lycées j'étais j allais un
peu recul en 10 ans mais est ce qu'ils
savent de quoi ça parle et ce qu'ils ont
entendu parler à ma grande surprise la
plupart des jeunes qu'on a rencontrés
avaient entendu parler de la loi comme
j'ai dis pas qu'il la connaissait dans
sa totalité qu'ils étaient capables de
la décrypter etc
mais il la connaissait donc les jeunes
aujourd'hui disent non pas nous pas
salariés kleenex demain ça c'est sûr
antoine chédid
on a peu entendu ces derniers jours le
front national sur le sujet on a
beaucoup entendu le front national sur
le sujet le front national s'est
clairement positionné contre la loi les
conneries je pense que ce qui concerne
cette première mobilisation c'est plutôt
bon parce que
effectivement lors de la première
manifestation contre le cpe avait fait
moins bien que celles de mercredi
dernier je suis donc avec monsieur du
front de gauche est par contre pour
revenir sur ce que disait monsieur
redesigned c'est que le problème c'est
pas une question de présentation de la
loi qui aurait été mal faite de mauvaise
communication
le fameux manque de pédagogie toujours
parce que les français sont des élèves
et que s'ils ne comprennent pas s'ils
sont contre c'est que ils ont mal
compris
non le problème c'est que le fond du
texte est mauvais le fond du texte c'est
la précarisation généralisée des
travailleurs français des salariés et ça
les salariés ils ne veulent pas ils ont
compris quelle était la logique derrière
ce texte ils ont très bien compris ne
sont pas bêtes alors il la refuse on va
venir sur le fond j'avais quand même
cette question sur la mobilisation parce
que alors chacun voit fait ses comptes
dans cette histoire tout de même on sait
que certains ne syndicat espérait une
mobilisation plus forte
est ce que ça dit quelque chose quand
même en train d'un décalage entre les
syndicats et le pays réel
aujourd'hui en france on sait que la
france n'est pas un pays très
syndicalisés de moins en moins
syndicalisés vous je vous vous dites non
vraiment je me doutais vous n'étiez pas
de cet avis vous vous pensez pas ça vous
pensez pas que le mouvement est plus
bien des 1000 à nevers il y avait 50
personnes par an non à auxerre par
exemple ils étaient entre 600 et 700 or
les renseignements généraux sont
d'accord là dessus mais c'est pas un
problème de nombre de cette semaine
mercredi
c'est un problème de fond de la
population qui sait et qui commence à se
rendre compte de manière plus pertinente
encore vers ce quoi on veut les mener un
monde du libéralisme complètement
déchaîné où toutes les règles sont
abolies et ça c'est qu'une étape 1 pour
le medef parce que le medef jusqu'au
bout il dira le contrat de travail tel
qu'il est on aurait pu la la suggestion
qui inclut dans un dans un contrat de
travail
ils veulent demain du gré à gré ça ils
l'ont ils l'ont expliqué en 2011
au cours d'un congrès et bien
aujourd'hui les françaises se rendent
compte qu'effectivement ce cancer du
libéralisme de ce capitalisme déchaîné
les conduit vers des situations de
précarité 2000
hier et demain ça sera pire on y
reviendra peut-être vous année sur le
fond bien sûr françois rebsamen je vous
vois tout ce qu'ils voulaient réagir
ça nous amène à ce qui doit être aussi
le coeur de cette émission c'est à dire
le fond de cette réforme
le contexte on le connaît en france
contexte le chômage de masse extrêmement
important je vais caricaturer les choses
l'esprit du texte c'est de donner plus
de flexibilité dans le temps de travail
dans la possibilité de licencier pour
des raisons économiques de limiter les
risques aux prud'hommes pour les
entreprises avec l'idée que ces
évolutions pousserait les entreprises à
embaucher
c'est une nouvelle après ce qu'on doit
dire que c'est une nouvelle approche
dans la gestion du droit du travail en
france et est ce que de votre point de
vue aux uns et aux autres il faut
essayer maintenant parce que leur sddd
façon de faire n'a pas fonctionné
françois que ça mais d'abord voudrait
dire en quelques mots moi je ne suis pas
un nostalgique du des manifestations du
cpe on croirait que il ya dans ce pays
une référence
il faut qu'il y ait autant de monde qui
avait pour le cpe ça n'a rien à voir
le cp portait sur la forme de
précarisation les jeunes ils en créent
un travail et là c'est un texte qui ne
vise pas ça est visé exactement le
contraire
il vise à donner de la souplesse aux
entreprises et il faut qu'elle ait de la
souplesse la sécurité et des droits aux
salariés et donc je rappelle quand même
que il ya une certaine grande faiblesse
syndicale de représentation syndicale 7
ou 8 % des salariés c'est vraiment très
faible mais il y a quand même dans les
entreprises un dialogue social qui
existe qui se développe chaque année il
ya trente-six mille accord d'entreprise
qui sont signés chaque année alors on
peut toujours gonfler les chiffres
simon vient ici ainsi 5 5 7 millions de
chômeurs en réalité si on prend les
chiffres de l'insee qui sont les
chiffres européens qui sert de
comparaison via en france au niveau de
l'insee c'est à dire des comparaisons du
bureau international du travail
deux millions huit cent soixante mille
chômeurs sait déjà qu des courses c'est
déjà assez c'est déjà trop c'est déjà
beaucoup trop mais on peut pas pour se
faire plaisir par les précarisation
généralisée
et parler de millions et de millions si
on ne part pas sur un diagnostic partagé
on peut pas avancer parce qu'elle est
davantage rey aujourd'hui avec vous
c'est au moins la vérité vous pourriez
maintenant 6 2 millions de chômeurs il a
beaucoup plu sans femmes ayant eu 107
101 plaisanterie les spectateurs
spectateurs pour vérifier deux millions
huit cent soixante mille la catégorie à
l'insee on avance un petit peu guillaume
larrivé qui rappe tant que subsiste
ensuite mais guillaume larrivé vous le
on va dire le caricature que je faisais
en tout cas le résumé très rapide de
cette loi
changer changer le paradigme pour
employer un mot compliqué et et flex
rendre les choses plus flexible est ce
que c'est quelque chose que la droite
voit d'un bon oeil ce que j'aimerais
vraiment c'est qu'on n'aborde pas ce
sujet en fonction des catégories
habituelle gauche/droite avec des
vieilles rengaines j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie non mais franchement j'ai
beaucoup de sympathie pour alain reymond
je voulais plus désolé non mais vraiment
vous êtes sincère vous êtes sur la ligne
pcf cgt la ligne historique du parti
communiste c'est très respectable et
vous faites avec sa série s'agit d'un
vrai militant sept c'est clair vous
front national c'est à peu près la même
leader vous l'avez dit moment c'est ce
que j'appelle la ligne hibernatus c'est
à dire on est congelé système qui
fonctionne pas voilà est ce que
j'aimerais manière vraiment pratique et
sans arrogance parce que quand tu vois
il ya tellement de souffrances tellement
de difficultés j'aimerais juste qu'on
soit pratique
j'étais hier dans une entreprise en
puisaye à rogny les sept écluses pour
pas la citer une petite entreprise
industrielle qui est donc dans un
territoire rural qui réussit à exporter
qui va conquérir des marchés qui
s'arrache pour parler de manière un peu
familier qu'est ce que nous disent les
salariés et les entrepreneurs de deux de
ses petites entreprises qu'on connaît
bien les uns et les autres dans nos
territoires
ils nous disent des choses assez simples
au fond laissez nous travailler alors
ils veulent pas rien raymond espèces
d'ultra libéralisme échevelé c'est pas
le grand capital avec un couteau entre
les dents non c'est pas ça
ce qu'ils veulent c'est un peu plus ceux
qui m'ont souplesse exemple un truc très
concret ils veulent que lorsqu'il se
sépare d'un salarié qui fait pas la
faire ils ont pas envie d'être tapés par
le par le tribunal des prud'hommes de
manière excessive et donc il faut qu'on
essaie
intelligemment de définir par exemple un
plafonnement des indemnités prud'homale
un plafonnement intelligent qui soit
assez protecteur des salariés mais qui
sécurise aussi des entreprises c'est ce
genre de solutions pratiques qu'il
faudrait être capable de rechercher que
l'on soit de gauche de droite de sang du
nord ou du sud qu'on se mette d'abord
dire que la loi travail non je ne dis
pas ça parce que je veux vraiment
station nombre de journées non non non
deux choses là dessus sur les chiffres
les toutous les chiffres des cités sont
les bons ça dépend dans quelle catégorie
on parle si on parle de toutes les
catégories a b c des draps on est à 5
millions 700 mille et quelques questions
parle que de la catégorisation mais on
va pas faire un débat de chiffres
ça c'est des statistiques officielles
sur le fond je ne vous dis pas
aujourd'hui ligne en mêlée que je vais
voter la loi les conneries puisque c'est
toujours ce n'est pas saisie on a un
avant projet manuel valls nous a dit
dans l'hémicycle qu'ils allaient
naturellement saisi le conseil d'état
d'une lettre rectificative ça dans une
modification de ce projet il y aura
peut-être un texte conseil des ministres
du 23 au 24 mars on en sera peut être
saisi ensuite
soyons précis moi ce que je veux c'est
juste dire que article après article
il ya peut-être des articles que veut
que je veux très chaud y aurait des
amendements
voilà soyons sérieux et n'attendons pas
n'attendons pas 2010 est une alternance
que j'espère est à laquelle on travaille
par ailleurs pour changer éventuellement
certains par alan qu'il y avait un
potentiel semaine quoi que je dise et
partant sur le texte lui-même en restons
au texte puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit
il y a deux dents je crois des articles
qui seront débattus à l'assemblée au
sénat
des articles qui constituent plus de
facilités pour l'entreprise pour
s'adapter au monde environnant et ça se
sent porté atteinte aux droits des
salariés
et puis pour moi il y à des articles qui
doivent être modifiées à mende et on
verra ce que le premier ministre
présentera lundi et ce qui sera le texte
qui sera soumis au conseil des listes
parce qu'on parle d'un texte qui n'est
pas encore soumis au conseil des
ministres
on verra cela dans quinze jours
indemnités prud'homale pour vous moi je
les sens il facilite les licenciements
économiques je peux en parler facilement
parce que j'ai fait avec christiane
taubira le tour de france des conseils
de prud'hommes des prud'hommes des
tribunaux de prud'hommes pour voir les
différences aujourd'hui les tribunaux de
prud'hommes rendent
jugement qui sont très différents d'un
territoire à l'autre est différent avec
des temps de réponse des délais de
réponses qui sont pénalisants et pour le
salarié et pour l'entreprise et donc je
pense qu'il faut essayer d'uniformiser
la jurisprudence
d'ailleurs les conseillers de
prud'hommes le demandent eux-mêmes et
donc après s'est soumis au débat
est-ce que les les indemnités prévues
sont un plancher ou un plafond
moi je peux aussi dire que ce que j'ai
vu c'est plutôt un plancher je veux dire
par là que en allemagne ces 24 mois
quand on a travaillé 20 ans on peut
monter là c'est quinze mois dans le
texte il faut modifier en faut modifier
ce marché insulaire suis allé un peu
vite sur le fond parce qu'en fait on
peut rendre même indicatifs indicatif ce
barème et puis je pense qu'il ne faut
pas modifier comme cela les conditions
du licenciement économique à la main du
passé donc c'est antoine chose il ya
quand même deux électorats au front
national un électorat ancien libéral et
puis un électorat populaire dans les
dernières élections
non je vous sens sur l'électorat
populaire sur ce mais oui effectivement
il n'ya pas de distinction à voir
puisque l'électorat du front national il
est d'accord sur l'essentiel à savoir
que vous parlez de nouvelles approches
par exemple c'est une nouvelle approche
cette loi mais moi ça fait depuis à peu
près que je m'intéresse à la politique
que j'entends le même disque ouvre ce
cloud by bull va comme ça un moderne au
libéral on nous explique qu'il faut
donner plus de pouvoir dans les
entreprises aux patrons plus de
latitudes plus de flexibilité plus de
liberté et que c'est comme ça qu'on va
re créé d'emplois ça fait des années
qu'on nous vend ses recettes là et que
ça ne marche pas que ça ne marche pas
monsieur l'arrivée nous parlait tout à
l'heure une barbe et quand quelque chose
que je comprends pas parce que c'est
présenté par la gauche de la gauche
comme un virage nouveau dans les
polinois en france donc ça fait c'est la
même logique libérale construit depuis
depuis que la france est engluée dans
l'euro à vrai dire mais je veux revenir
sur ce que disait monsieur l'arrivée sur
le besoin des entreprises alors ça c'est
formidable toujours pas ce qu'on à
chaque fois qu'un homme politique de
visiter une entreprise ils entendent
toujours exactement ce qu'il envie
d'attendre c'est assez inouï il se
trouve que quand l'insee interroge les
chefs d'entreprise si la réponse est un
peu différente les chefs d'entreprises
10 à 40 7% que leur problème c'est que
le carnet de commandes n'est pas assez
rempli il ya un problème de 2
en france ils sont 14% à dire qu'il ya
un pas qu'ils ont eu un problème d'offre
donc vous voyez bien que le on
s'interroge toujours sur les mauvaises
questions sur les mauvaises questions et
donc je suis assez content aujourd'hui
pour l'instant monsieur l'arrivée soit à
peu près d'accord finalement avec
monsieur rebsamen
je suis content de l'entendre dire que
le clivage droite gauche n'est plus
pertinente aujourd'hui pour regarder les
débats qui ont lieu parce
qu'effectivement ce débat là c'est pas
le bon le débat il est entre ceux qui
acceptent la logique européenne de
l'euro qui fait que si la france veut
rester compétitif effectivement elles
doivent procéder à ce qu'on appelle de
la dévaluation interne par la baisse des
salaires par la précarisation
l'alternative c'est la sortie de l'euro
la monnaie nationale et donc la
dévaluation décidée à l'extérieur
puisque j'ai parlé d'europe puisque vous
parlez d'europe finances et josh bailey
pour relancer la discussion guillaume
larrivé que les téléspectateurs
comprennent un certain nombre de pays
européens l'allemagne on a beaucoup
parlé de l'allemagne on a parlé de
l'espagne et du portugal l'italie
récemment françois hollande était en
italie ou matteo renzi envoyer un
message aux français on a vu qu'un
certain nombre de pays qui ont fait le
choix qui en gros est à peu de choses
près toutes choses égales par ailleurs
mais le projet de la loi une connerie
ont vu leur chômage baisser est ce que
la france
non mais je vous pose la question à tous
les cas les oiseaux ligne ont signé ce
qui m'intéresserait mais au tout le
monde au delà de la récitation du
catéchisme et et des fiches non mais
c'est bon enfin je veux dire ça c'est
immonde langage de monsieur philippe au
tout ça n'a aucun intérêt il faut être
extrêmement concret par exemple
l'entreprise que j'ai visités dont
qu'hier il ya 47 salariés
pourquoi il ya 47 salariés et pas 50
pour une question
on a déjà beaucoup débattu à l'assemblée
au sénat connaît par parker également
dans ces niches du travail la fameuse
question des seuils
ben voila moi je suis de ceux qui disent
qu elle tacle qu' il faut que ont
suspendu les effets pervers de ces
seuils pendant quelques années voire
même qu'on est qu'on les supprime tout
simplement parce qu'il ya des
entreprises j'en connais pas mal de
travail
ne pas la citer elle à 49 salariés elle
veut pas en avoir 50 parce qu'il ya un
problème de seuil c'est ce genre de
rigidité au delà des mots de la théorie
qu'il ya deux trois sujets comme ça
qu'on crée qu'il faut traiter on a 800
articles dans le code du travail il faut
en toile était certain ça veut pas dire
qu'on mettra tout à bas messieurs
marival et sociaux c'est nicolas sarkozy
ne les a pas modifié
je réponds ça tout n'a pas été fait je
suis très à l'aise là dessus en 2016 on
avait fait son nombre critique et ce
soir on fait des choses ça n'a pas été
fait en effet mais il faudra que ce soit
fait voilà on encore ça dépend comment
on veut avancer
moi j'entends ce qui est dit et j'avais
moi même proposé à un moment qu'on
suspende pendant trois ans le seuil des
pourquoi parce qu'il ya deux fois plus
et demi deux fois et demie plus
d'entreprise de 49 que l'entreprise de
51,20 plus qu'à côté stable donc je me
disais wallon avant son ensemble dans le
cadre du dialogue social
j'ai soumis je l'avais expliqué à
l'assemblée j'ai soumis aux partenaires
sociaux cette proposition elle a été
rejetée dans le cadre du dialogue social
moi je considère qu'on ne peut pas
avancer sans avoir des accords avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
donc je vous dois accepter je donne cet
élément mais si vous permettez justement
entendu a ajouté cela parce que je vous
mets en garde aussi quand vous avez un
jour la démocratie fera que vous serez à
nouveau au pouvoir
ne croyez pas qu'on peut faire sans le
dialogue social et si vous faites sans
dialogue social c'est l'oeuf celle de
cpe pour le coup c'est juppé avec des
millions de gens dans la rue donc on ne
peut avancer qu'en dialoguant en
écoutant et en essayant de rassembler au
maximum je sais ce que vous cette saison
2 alors est-ce que c'est passionnant
c'est très démonstrative je ne doute pas
de la bonne volonté qui était celle de
françois rebsamen quand il a voulu en
effet suspendre les effets de seuil est
effectivement une gilles de 50 à celui
des 50
il nous dit à l'instant j'ai pas fait ce
qu'il n'y avait pas d'accord syndicale
je crois vraiment que la mutation
profonde et marronnage sommes
précisément l'une des raisons des
blocages français depuis tant d'années
vous avez évoqué le plan juppé ya 20 ans
l'une des raisons des blocages français
c'est sans doute de mon point de vue
cela et donc moi ce que j'aimerais
vraiment beaucoup
c'est qu'un jour on vienne devant les
français sans doute avant 17 qu'on dit
des choses qu'on obtient un mandat via
l'élection et qu'ensuite on le fasse
peut-être françois rebsamen et c'est une
différence entre nous peut-être en
contournant pour le coup la nécessité
d'un accord des syndicats
moi je pense qu'il faut parler
directement aux français là dessus et
les faire trancher et qui dit quand vous
discutez de la rencontre boudeuse si
vous voulez hein
j'ai entendu deux choses de la part de
monsieur rebsamen tout à l'heure comme
ça en prenant des choses il ne veut
discuter qu'avec les syndicats dits
réformistes donc avec la sérénité je
suppose
avec ce qui doit bien ça fera plaisir
aux autres qui vont se sentir exclu faut
reconnaître deuxièmement je leur ai
mi-raisin classiques mais aussi le rêve
semaine vente le dialogue social où elle
dialogue social quand on use est tombé
ce projet de loi ça c'est extraordinaire
parce que personne n'a dit à
l'oxygénation qu'est ce que c'est ce
qu'ils sont à ce point françois hollande
avait voulu il n'y a pas eu de dialogue
social en même temps françois hollande
avait fait de la jeunesse sa priorité
est aujourd'hui elle est dans la rue
beau succès de votre bolide en parler
parce que je suis pas certain toute la
jeunesse soit dans la rue pour revenir
dans la figure en 2010 5 alors excusez
moi et pour monsieur l'arrivée qu'ils
soient tout mettre par terre on va pas
tout mettre par terre je suis désolé moi
je vais vous rappeler si vous les ai pas
entendu les propos de monsieur fillon
cette semaine c'est quand même bon c'est
pas votre cheval celui que vous avez
choisi pour gagner la course mais peu
importe vous retrouvez en kiosque fillon
alice elle se mêle nord vous êtes à
paris vous êtes député aussi fillon
alliés auxerre en 2017 si je suis
président de la république dès le mois
de juin parle 49,3 par les ordonnances
je supprime le code du travail voilà ce
qu'il a dit cette semaine donc ne s'agit
pas aujourd'hui de dire n'importe quoi
alors l'esprit du code du travail c'est
ça qui est la hiérarchie des normes et
bouleversé la hiérarchie des normes et
complètement 12h15 dix anciens point ce
genre catastrophique c'est un vrai sujet
d'un jeu c'est pas vrai si parce que
l'épave avant il y avait la loi il y
avait l'accord de branche et il y avait
l'entreprise voilà ce qu'il faudrait
heures les problèmes du côté des
chômeurs et que le chômeur aujourd'hui
initiative mais il a quelque chose à se
dire sur la hiérarchie des normes et
bouleversé est ce que les gens qui sont
au chômage aujourd'hui du succès les
intéressent et s'il ya ce qui les
intéresse c'est vrai plus de travail en
france pose la question de cette manière
là
s'il ya plus de hiérarchie des normes
comme il y avait le salarié ce trou il
restait dans la négociation avec son
chef d'entreprise avec un pistolet sur
la tempe
on le sait regarder smart ce qui s'est
passé par exemple
donc soit resté sage et la hiérarchie
des accords d'entreprise puis oui mais
depuis le début du contrat de travail
2le du code du travail la hiérarchie des
normes a été celle qu'on veut la donner
l'occasion sera bonne chose il peut
parler puisqu'il attend patiemment
excellent c'est le benjamin de ce
plateau et fofolle l'on croyait janvier
moi je suis d'accord avec ce que vous
dites
le chômeur ce qui ce qui les intéresse
c'est d'avoir du travail et donc c'est
pour ça moi je m'interroge je me dis la
flexibilisation du marché du travail
pour créer de l'emploi est ce que ça
marche à l'étranger est ce que ça a
marché parce qu'elle fait ou bien vous
avez raison tout à l'heure vous disais
que ça a été fait par la théorie lancés
des 500000 ses délires les verts matin
un rapport qui a été fait par trois
économistes dont un de sciences po donc
que j'ai pas eu la chance d'avoir le
professeur en art afana dario garracio
d'accord sur la réforme du marché du
travail italien
je vais vous lire la conclusion parce
que quand je lis du des travaux
académiques de ce genre j'ai rarement lu
des travaux académiques avec des
conclusions aussi naïve chômeurs de
moins la conclusion était très nette le
jackpot qui a lieu le nom de législation
italienne le job act apparaît comme
inefficaces en termes de quantité
qualité et de durée des emplois créés
parce que le jeu
la flexibilisation du marché du travail
en italie n'a pas créé d'emplois elle en
a détruit
elle n'a pas amélioré la qualité du
travail à la détériorer puisque la
roumanie fait tout le monde n'a pas les
mères tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
conclusions
eh ben c'est intéressant puisque on en
sent en europe des choses des chiffres
totalement opposés sur des pays qui ont
fait des choix gamme sensibilisation du
marché du travail
créer des petits boulots créer de
l'emploi à mi temps à temps partiel des
difficultés des travailleurs précarisés
oui c'est parce que nous voulons pour la
france c'est ce qui va arriver choix que
nous avons fait pour la france
nous voulons des travailleurs sécurisés
dans leur travail et les accords
d'entreprise c'est pas le renversement
des normes si les leurs mais non nous
n'en faisons pas trente six mille que si
la cgt chaque année alors attendu si
bien sûr leur certain nombre de choix
alors au niveau local sur le code du
travail c revient pas vous changez la
place et éviter la contagion
cessna social en allemagne en allemagne
y avait 8 % c'était différent en
allemagne avait 8 % qui avait fait là
sion il y avait de la croisière vers une
y avait un taux de pauvreté des
chauffeurs d'allemagne qu'ils étaient 32
% le taux de pauvreté chauffeur allemand
était de 32%
il était de 32% des français cinq ans
plus tard mais rôde le taux de pauvreté
des chômeurs allemands il est de 70 % le
taux de pauvreté chômeurs français
il n'a pas bougé donc nous avons un
système qui est sécurisé est-ce qu'il
est trop rigide peut-être on peut le
faire bouger
c'est ça que je dis tout simplement dans
l'intérêt pour faire rentrer des jeunes
sur le marché du travail il en rentre
d'ailleurs des jeunes sur le marché du
travail
ils trouvent du travail au bout d'un
certain temps un million rentrer il ya
aujourd'hui un taux de chômage des
jeunes un taux de chômage des jeunes par
rapport à l'emploi qui situe aux
alentours de huit et demi pour cent
c'est énorme mais c'est que huit et demi
pourcent faut aussi relativiser les
choses et donc les jeunes ils vont
trouver du travail c'est pas la peine de
les désespérer ceux qui sont formés je
vous en fais des études ils trouveront
du travail
mais si on veut les faire rentrer
plusieurs téléchargements que le travail
allait les faire rentrer plus vite dans
le monde du travail c'est ce que nous
souhaitons et comment les faire rentrer
plus vite dans le travail
et bien tout simplement en essayant de
sécuriser leur embauche par des plus
part des cdi par des cdd
c'est ça que nous voulons est
aujourd'hui si 80% de cdd qui a raison
les embauches alors
il nous reste ce temps avant la fin de
cette première partie en fin de semaine
a dit tout à l'heure ce qu'ils voulaient
l'aimerait je vais voir modifier dans ce
projet est ce que vous trouvez qu'il ya
des points pour j'ai bien compris ce
qu'est une opposition assez forte pour
certains mais des points positifs tout
de même dans ce projet à la raymond par
exemple le comte d'activité c'est
quelque chose qui vous semblent
positives il ya de positif puisque
l'esprit au départ est mauvais et
renverse tout donc il faut enterrer ce
fameux projets et reprendre langue avec
les syndicats
non mais si on sait très bien que vous
avez choisi une voie qui est celle là
celle de la voix de l'offre de la
politique de l'offre du libéralisme à
tous crins de bon sens et vous avez vous
et on vous en dit vous êtes de gauche
encore genoux même sans doute le dit
bon personne la gauche ya longtemps vous
l'avait abandonnée si vous avez
abandonné
moi je me permets de vous dire ça
monsieur vous avez abandonné y compris
j'aurais su j'aurais pas de leçon à
recevoir de rien j'aurais stipendiés les
chômeurs y'a pas longtemps quand il
était ministre du travail
brises l'accusé à ce que j'ai d'ailleurs
une cour de ne pas chercher fait pas le
travail voilà j'ai fait la leçon à
recevoir d'un gp c'est pas vrai des
choses qui sont arrivées il ya quelque
chose de positif pour vous qu'est ce que
vous trouvez positif je trouve mais
arrêtez ce que je trouve très négatifs
ces espèces de posture encore une fois
c'est très bien le parti communiste
c'est très sympathique on devrait
d'ailleurs je trouve même créé des
musées entraînement pour ça serait très
sain pays je constate que le front
national est sur ce dossier exactement
sur la même position 1 re édition
mélenchon position le pen identique nous
ne modifions pas le code du travail
sortant de l'euro voilà c'est la même
ligne non non j'ai pas révélé si un plan
économique l'économie au coeur
économique
ça peut être un peu embêtant pour vous
mais pour eux rien enfin je constate
politique julien ce sont des gens
constatent je constate
aujourd'hui front national question
khodeiry sur auvergne et sur une idée
aux communistes grosso modo sa
résurrection de georges marchais si on
va un tout petit peu sérieux méandres
ans que mon sujet en trente secondes
article après article
par exemple moi je souhaite si la loi
comme rivier au parlement je présenterai
un amendement avec mes collègues
républicains sur ces histoires de seuil
pour essayer de contourner le refus par
exemple ça favorable contrairement au
parti communiste front national mais je
suis plutôt favorable à ce qu'on essaie
de trouver des accords d'entreprise pour
s'organiser dans les entreprises voient
là pour donner un comité d'entreprise
est obligé de couper vous entendez mais
on va continuer ses discussions après
les informations de midi en particulier
aura la question des conséquences qui va
se passer dans les semaines et et dans
les mois à venir a tout de suite je
t'appelle informations